the Joe Rogan experience what I want to
see more even than the DC thing I want
to see Francis and gunner steep a -
because Francis and Gahan who just
destroyed Cain and Junior dos Santos who
if you guys remember those were the guys
that's the heavyweight division and he
just destroyed both of them he looks
like he got his confidence back he looks
like you know like I want to see that
rematch yeah I'm uh I'm terrified for
everybody who gets in the Octagon every
time he fights somebody I'm like yeah
because I remember I remember I still
have like shell-shocked for watching
Alistair Overeem get hit with that left
hook I remember that was the hardest
knockout I've ever seen I remember can
like no one's gonna survive that it
looked like the back of Alistair
Overeem's had touched his ankles I was
like no one everyone's going out from
that everyone's going out called that's
the heavyweights you have to like have
so much respect because it's like holy
[ __ ] dude like you're getting in there
and it's just like at any moment you're
just gone you know I'd rather fight a
heavyweight then like 135 pounder though
just to be a thousand times in the head
that's the punch bro there should be a
t-shirt like justice it's interesting
you say that with DC where you're like I
just know in like in as like as little
as we know Mickey Gaul as much like
we've been friends with him for a short
amount of time even like when he fights
there's some different like stakes on it
as a buddy you're like and you don't see
that Ally and you're calling it like you
can't like put my chart for me when
cowboy fights I root against the start
actually really hard when Brendan was
widening I was hard cuz I'm real tight
with him mm-hmm
we're really good friends and when he
wasn't really doing it anymore he was
still in it but he wasn't really like a
hundred percent end he was thinking
about other things he was thinking about
when he gets out it wasn't it didn't
have the same focus and intensity and
training as used to that's hard that's
not the sport to do that yeah oh it's
hard whenever you're thinking about
getting out get out get out because
there's people that aren't thinking
about get now and you got to think about
what we were talking about earlier Mike
Tyson is prime angry at everything like
if you're thinking about getting out and
you
in front of a guy like that you know or
a girl like that this is this female
kickboxers that are like that too
they're just [ __ ] vicious man and
they're waiting you think you're half in
half out thinking about cheerleading
Wham shin to the face at the end Brendon
could have been beaten by a woman yes
the [ __ ] highest levels of any combat
sport you have to be all in I don't
think I don't think that's something you
could dabble in it's a hard thing that
because I think in MMA like you know
luckily brendan is a you know podcaster
comedian I think a lot of other guys
they don't have the same but they could
do other stuff like tyron woodley is
rapping tyron woodley has businesses I
know he's doing something with CBD I
know God he did a record with Wiz
Khalifa I know he does a lot of TMZ
stuff he's a funny dude I think you have
to become the ally look tyrants
smart champion though it's like I here's
a huge name was but he's still he's
working see he lost his title to Iran
but yet he's still doing all these other
things of course but I think it's easier
when you when you have that name you're
a former UFC champion I think that alone
will probably sort of set you up as long
as you're not push elite idiot for the
rest of your life but they're guys that
never get to that very very top and if
they don't sort of set themselves up for
afterwards they're gonna you know when
you think about getting a deal I should
do the reason they take those fights
what was that one documentary I saw
where the guy was like you've got like
crazy brain injuries and his family was
just like - don't take another fight and
he still had to take it he's had to pay
the bills and it was just like there was
just another option he was like barely
making money at a gym so that's the
thing where it's like is a sport where
you're all in and then once that kind of
[ __ ] hits the fan it reminds with comedy
cuz like it takes minimum five to ten
years to figure out if you're gonna even
be good enough to do it professionally
right and then at that point it's your
whole life so that's why you never see
people quitting nobody quits gonna do
you see a lot of people with it maybe
they start it like 20 and like by 30
they're ten years in and if it's not
working out for you you took the 10
years when you were supposed to be
figuring out where the trajectory of
like everyone you knew from high school
figured out a job got a house got mad or
what
[Applause]